hey guys welcome back and today's video
is going to be talking about some of the
stuff of things going on yesterday and
today whether that's going to read it
Ernie post that's been updated by for
honor or anybody in Ubisoft now today
kind of good [ __ ] day so one the dev
stream is not up today it should have
been ups today and what I had a video on
it today but there was none today they
had to push it back for whatever [ __ ]
reason that was so they never did state
in this reddit post why they post or why
they pushed it back but they just simply
said they did and they're going to do it
later this week hopefully big word on
hopefully they said they were also going
to come out weekly content and that
felled in the first week so honest is
going to be surprised if we don't get a
warrior's then a little live stream and
you won't see a video for me about it so
don't be surprised on top of that they
even asked this they have this little
thing on the live stream where they do
the call for creations people send in
cool clips or cool fan art that they
made and they kind of send it and then
it could be in a giveaway or some other
stuff like that this is the problem
though they say at the bottom by
submitting your content in this thread
you understand that you are granting
Ubisoft a worldwide royalty-free license
to modify and use your content newbie
sales marketing assets to be distributed
on Ubisoft social social channels own
websites and other media outlets you
will not receive any green new narration
or other sort of competition whether
your content a selective modified or
used pursuit into the license above big
emphasis on the content selected and
modified portion that means Ubisoft can
give you you can send your little
sculpture or fan art to Ubisoft they can
toy with it whatever they want and they
will not pay you for it you are giving
them free stuff why would we give first
all to this company free stuff anyway
when they're basically [ __ ] us over
with a game and not explaining us what
we're sport what we're supposed to
expect in the next week and a half and
on top of that you won't get paid for
this and Ubisoft is really a really
popular company by the way they have
like a net worth of like what 500
million to a 1 billion dollars I don't
think they need this I think they can
give a few some cash to some
of these generous people now in for some
small good news but not exactly some
good news you might have seen in the
title and the thumbnail of peacekeeper
being bend no sadly she's not banned
from the game I wish well she is banned
from tournament play MLG e league
themselves even stated that peacekeeper
will not be allowed in tournament in any
tournament of for honor up until they
fix her basically there was a recent
tournament in basically from the
quarterfinals to the semi-final all the
way to the finals match it was nothing
but peacekeeper super boring just really
annoying and it just proves the Helen
knowing this character can get and how
overpowered this character is so
hopefully that's a wake-up call to
Ubisoft bday cake mixer or something a
good thing on unique to definitely step
in with that and to top it all off we
have another server outage apparently
the servers have been done for the past
six hours I haven't been playing any for
honor today I'm playing the new Dark
Souls 3 DLC loving the [ __ ] out of it
it's actually kind of nice to take some
time out of for honor and the
frustration to get into this game but
it's just I just wish that Ubisoft would
at least listen to us I know all of you
that have subscribed to this channel 44
honor love this game you all enjoy that
that's why you bought it it looked
interesting yes it's a ubisoft game so
Monday's some of you might have been
skeptical but hey Rainbow six siege did
well whatever division of Ubisoft made
rainbow succeeds needs to come and just
take like a week and a half to two weeks
to stop doing anything rainbow six and
help out for honor because holy [ __ ] do
we need help I also notice that in the
reddit a lot of people were bashing you
be space elephant which is one of the
main model Raiders on the reddit guys
chill out with him like he's a great guy
he doesn't really work for Ubisoft he's
just a moderator for that read a page
that pins in Dutton comments but he's
basically a pretty big deal on reddit
but he's practically as powerless as us
when it comes to telling you be solve
something so just chill out with any of
that stuff I just hope that this game
can get fixed and something that these
developers watch it listen to us and
hopefully this game can sprout it to
something
amazing anyway guys is just going to be
for the video hope y'all did enjoy I'm
going to have a video in the next couple
days whether that be a discussion video
on is there going to be the faction more
the contract order so be out for that or
if they end up releasing the dev stream
I'll be doing everything they discussed
in that or they're just going to sit
around and do nothing than there so then
it would be a waste of time but i will
probably update you on whether or not on
one of those two videos so be on the
lookout for those guys did enjoy the
video please slap a like on that really
does help me out really does grow this
channel a lot as you know it doesn't
seem like it if you've never visited if
you're very new to this channel and
you've never seen me before hit that
subscribe button I got tons of four on
our stuff coming out so be on the
lookout for that guy's in a piece i'll
see you all later have a great day boys